The Legend of Zelda is full of relics
and important items that alter the story
or even the way you play the game
sometimes both these relics come in all
shapes and sizes but of all the iconic
gadgets and artifacts that have been in
our minds over the years few have stood
out as much as the legendary ocarina of
time be it because it comes from a game
of the same name that many Zelda fans
today myself included accredit as being
their introduction to the series or the
fact that it holds the power of
manipulating well time itself no one can
deny its impact of the franchise as a
whole but one thing that's always kind
of bugged me is the mystery surrounding
its origin I mean we eventually got an
answer for where the Master Sword came
from it was forged from the goddess
sword but the ocarina of time never gets
a similar explanation what makes it
different than any other ocarina and why
you know besides the fact that it's blue
which we'll get into later by the way
and on that note without further ado
allow me to humbly present who made the
ocarina of time
[Music]
so let's start off by making sure
everyone's on the same page width of the
Ocarina of Time this massively important
relic comes from the game of the same
name
Zelda Ocarina of Time shocking I know it
also makes a huge appearance in the
direct sequel Majora's Mask it first
comes into Lynx possession when Zelda is
being rushed away from the castle on
horseback because the evil Ganondorf is
attacking the royal family in an effort
to seize the ocarina for himself in an
instant moment of decision Zelda throws
the precious ocarina into the moat
surrounding the castle praying that link
would find it and protect it from the
wiles of the Gerudo king
shortly after Ganondorf appears and asks
link directly which way Zelda had fled
link enormous Lea brave even as a child
without the Triforce of courage refuses
to answer and gets knocked out because
of it little did Ganondorf know that the
ocarina was a few feet behind him in the
moat and by not killing the child link
he had already sealed his own fate but
story times over back to talking about
the ocarina throughout the course of the
two games the little blue instrument is
used to accomplish several things like
opening the door of time revealing the
Master Sword in the Sacred Realm
which is why Ganondorf was looking for
it in the first place warping linked to
different temples and even slowing down
speeding up and rewinding time itself
truly these games wouldn't have even
been possible without the mysterious
wind instrument heck the rest of the
games in the timeline wouldn't either
but what we're told in game about its
origins is essentially nothing in
ocarina of time the only words that we
have that may allude to its creation are
said by Zelda when link meets her in the
courtyard for the first time you know
that scene whether spying on the man
with the evil eyes she's explaining to
link that the Sacred Realm is accessible
through the temple of time and through
it you can access the master sword and
the Triforce that is when she states
simply that according to legend the door
of time can be opened with three
spiritual stones and the ocarina the
ocarina being associated with said
legend this really doesn't reveal much
to us besides the notion that the
ocarina may be
Ange
it's passed down from generation to
generation or whatever being part of a
legend means so with its actual direct
quote unquote origin stated to be none
other than legend I decided to look
elsewhere for clues on its creation of
course these days one of the first
places to look for any things or related
outside of the games would be the
official zone literature we have all
been blessed with in recent years for
the newest title breath of the wild the
book creating a champion is a fantastic
resource to kind of read in between the
lines of the games locations and
characters for all things non breath of
the wild we have the original goddess
collection trilogy which includes the
widely acclaimed Hyrule historia which I
consulted for clues surrounding the
Ocarina of times origins in the book on
pages 53 and 86 it alludes twice to a
very key characteristic the ocarina
sculler
the book states that it's blue white
radiance brings to mind the timeshift
stones found in the eras of antiquity
now what are the timeshift stones you
asked for those that have played Skyward
Sword that name should ring a bell in
the linear approach and being mined in
the Linnea mining facility these rocks
are present and revealed to have innate
time-shifting properties hence the name
this creates some really nifty gameplay
aesthetics like the mind-blowing notion
of creating a force field around the
stones that inside said force field
jumps time to centuries in the past
while outside it seamlessly is still in
the present the book seems to imply that
the ocarina may actually be made of the
same material which of course would
possibly give some explanation to its
innate ability to manipulate time
looking closer at the stones themselves
there are some more clues we can gather
about the ocarina scree a ssin clearly
marked on their surfaces is the early
symbol of the sheikah clan an ancient
people group dedicated to the service of
highly and the protection of the royal
family who are descendants of Hylian the
sheikah have always been technologically
advanced for their time as we also see
in breadth of the wild so the notion
that the mining facility and therefore
study and excavation of the timeshift
stones themselves being a sheikah
project is rather believable wouldn't
you agree
perhaps they worked closely with the
dragon linear route to develop the
powerful technology to serve hi Leah
perhaps it even continued onward to be
the technology that we see in breath of
the wild but that's kind of besides the
point with the timeshift stones and
sheekha's probable relations in mind I
began to search what we know of the
sheikah clan for any possible
connections to instruments or music and
wouldn't you know it
not only to define connections but I
found composers back in ocarina of time
the game that is the sheikah have a
strong presence surrounding many events
that transpire not only is Ashika elder
Impa the protector of princess zelda and
the one that teaches you Zelda's Lullaby
but there's an entire town that used to
be an exclusively sheikah populated town
called Kakariko village the village now
open to the public still contains many
of its old secrets from the sheikah that
once resided there such as the
mysterious shadow temple and the
monsters at the bottom of the well but
what I'm getting at and what's gonna tie
this place in with the creation of the
ocarina is found in the graveyard
the graveyard is home to the Buried
corpses of the sheikah as expected it is
here that you can meet the ghosts or
pose of two brothers who once served the
royal family in life and now serve them
in death meet the composer brothers
sharp and flat sharp says himself that
he and his brother were born long ago in
Kakariko and states that all who were
born there were destined to serve the
royal family signifying that they are in
fact members of the sheikah clan these
brothers were musical scientists who
were able to conduct several different
songs that alter reality such as the
sons song and possibly even the song of
storms although that one's more
theoretical since that information comes
from Majora's Mask where the brothers
also make an appearance and in that game
flat is said to have conducted it but
that entire game takes place in termina
which is a land not even confirmed to
actually exist but anyway they also
studied the power of the triforce and
vowed to protect it along with the royal
family
the most notable discovery the brothers
were able to find comes from their study
of the control over time via musical
tones from ocarina
as this beginning to sound familiar the
brothers claim they actually finished
that study and in so doing attracted the
attention of Ganondorf however in a
tragic dark twist to protect the secrets
they discovered they took their
lives before Ganondorf could get what he
wanted out of them at this point I was
certain we had our answer staring us in
the face so let's break down all the
clues we've talked about so far and
conclude this mystery the ocarina is
said to be made of timeshift stones a
material known to the sheikah who are
sworn to protect the royal family and
triforce the composer brothers brilliant
sheikah scientists completed a study
regarding controlling time that
attracted the attention of Ganondorf who
was already shown in game to be
searching for the ocarina Ganondorf
probably wouldn't have been attracted to
the composer brothers studies if they
remained simply words on paper no given
the sheekha's background in technology
and the timeshift stones completing
their study and Ganondorf hearing about
it most likely means they actually
completed the creation of the ocarina of
time and upon ganondorf's intrusion
entrusted the instrument to the Elder
Impa prior to taking their own lives
this would explain why Impa has musical
knowledge and why zelda ultimately had
possession of the ocarina
with Ganondorf chasing after her Wow it
all makes sense now of course this isn't
confirmed in black and white on paper
but what do you think did I convince you
or is the ocarina of legend more ancient
than what I talked about let me know in
the comments below thank you all so very
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this exciting little theory if you did
be sure to like this video and subscribe
if you haven't already for much more
juicy Zelda and Nintendo content to come
as always humongous thank you to my
faithful patrons including my newest one
blossom possum cosplay and actually
she's a wonderful cosplay artist so
please be sure to check her out on
Instagram I'll link to it and my patreon
page for those interested in getting
your names up here in the description
below also in the description are links
to my discord and Twitter and other ways
to connect with me directly you know if
you want to anyway that's all I've got
for you in this video I hope you're all
having a fantastic kickoff to 2020 and
that you have a great rest of your day
this is Masson Hannah Bandits signing
out
[Music]